great thanks for the introduction again
michael and thanks everyone for for
coming
uh the the topic i wanted to talk about
today is design tools for digital
fabrication and um
as many of you may know
digital fabrication has become probably
one of the most kind of active or hot
topics in computer graphics which is
kind of mainly the community that i come
from but as well as as well as hci
so
you know why have i and to be fair
others as well kind of jumped on this
this fabrication bandwagon so to speak
well one thing one reason that you've
probably heard before
is the rise of digital fabrication and
technology so things like 3d printers
laser cutters cnc machines these things
are becoming
more affordable and more accessible than
ever before
and that's making it possible to create
a variety of different things in a
variety of different materials
easier than ever before as well so
i think that that seems to present or
offer an opportunity to think about and
develop some new
user interfaces and interaction
techniques as well as computational
tools to help people create this variety
of different types of physical artifacts
okay so so that's kind of the status and
i was just i just tried to look back
over some of my favorite fabrication
papers over the last several years and i
found that you know more or less they
kind of fell into three broad categories
so there's been a lot of projects that
focus on building design tools that
empower new users so these are people
who may not have the expertise to use
traditional cad or cam tools to create
things
to design for fabrication and so
there have been systems we've seen
systems for helping people build
kind of complex furniture as well as
figurines that can balance and stand on
their own
another category of work is just
exploring the new types of things that
we can create with rapid prototyping
technologies and
some of you may have seen the work by
willis at all on printed optics where
they embed these 3d printed light pipes
inside of objects to create
or enable these kind of dynamic and
tangible display surfaces
also valkyrie savage and their
colleagues at berkeley have been working
on a few different techniques for
creating
3d printed tangible input components
like game controllers or mixing boards
let's say that are kind of functional
they're interactive they work with
computers but they don't require you to
actually wire up a bunch of electronics
in there they use things like computer
vision
and audio signal processing to detect
detect and interpret these interaction
events
and finally there's this kind of
interesting category of new work
that's been coming out that really looks
to understand the the understand design
workflows that make use of digital
fabrication and try to improve or
optimize those workflows so in
particular um stephanie mueller and her
colleagues at hpi have done a lot of
really cool recent work that tries to
just you know figure out some of the
inefficiencies in existing design
workflows that involve 3d printing and
just minimize those those or kind of
work on those inefficiencies to try to
make um
to try to make design iteration much
quicker
so these are three kind of broad
categories of work there are probably
other ones most of what i'll talk about
today falls into this first category um
but i'm interested in these other
categories as well and i'm hoping that
at some point i get a chance to work on
some projects uh in that
in those domains
okay so if we're talking about trying to
empower new users to design for
fabrication who might these users be um
well i think on one hand
some of them could very well be
industrial designers
so
these are people who are already kind of
embedded already participating in the
process of creating physical things
but in some cases at least
not all these designers may have the
kind of engineering or cad expertise to
create
working physical models on their own so
maybe they have to work with uh
mechanical engineers or a print shop and
so the opportunity here is i think to
kind of reduce the that kind of friction
in the design workflow and hopefully
make it easier for designers to create
and fabricate some of these objects
themselves and then
hopefully thereby iterate more quickly
there's also a large community of makers
out there who are interested in creating
a wide variety of different types of
objects and again you know these people
may not have the expertise to create
physical objects completely on their own
and then finally there's
you know i think
what i would call just a long tail of of
other people um maybe let's just call
them consumers this is kind of a
like a really common term that's bandied
about in in
adobe probably other companies as well
it's like oh this is a block of people
they're consumers it means they're
willing to spend money on something
but for consumers i think for these
consumers the interest may be more in
terms of just kind of personalizing some
of the objects that they that they buy
or they have in uh in their possession
so maybe putting uh photographs on their
on their iphone cases or
maybe designing exactly you know which
combinations of colors or materials your
shoe should be composed of so
you know this is kind of a they're a
very different i think segment than uh
designers and makers but they're still
kind of interested in participating in
the this kind of design process at some
level
so in addition to having all these
different types of of a potential users
you know obviously there's lots of
different domains of physical objects
that we might consider when we're
thinking about building design tools so
you know clothing and furniture and
jewelry maybe even you want to design
your own modern prefab house
so
each of these domains probably uh
consists of some of
or
produces some of its own challenges with
respect to developing effective design
tools um
in the last part of my talk i will
discuss what i think are some
opportunities that kind of may span some
of the
many of these different categories but
for most of today i'll be talking about
some work that falls under the category
of kind of mechanism design and
in particular i'll talk about two
projects
one that focuses more on kind of
enabling hobbyists to create
great working mechanical objects and the
other one that focuses more on on
designers
okay so
why
are
mechanical objects kind of an
interesting domain to look at
well first of all they're extremely
common and
you know you may be thinking about
things like cars and construction
equipment and other kind of industrial
machinery these are clearly all examples
of mechanical objects but kind of at a
smaller more kind of day-to-day scale
things like there are things like toys
like wind up toys for instance and also
just lots of household objects
consist of mechanical components so um
there are lots of these mechanical
objects out there and the other thing is
that they they tend to be pretty
difficult to to design so
there's lots of parameters that are
associated with these mechanical objects
and those parameters are coupled and
constrained in interesting and
challenging ways so there may be kind of
like a pretty big parameter space of
designs to consider but only a
relatively small set is is actually
valid or it does what you wanted to do
and so while you know people with a
mechanical engineering background or an
industrial design background
may
be capable of kind of finding the this
right set of parameters it can be a
pretty daunting task for um you know for
other designers or for hobbyists and
certainly for novices so
you know the the question is how can we
kind of help these different types of
users create some of these mechanical
mechanical objects
okay so so before i get into the
specifics of a couple these two projects
that i'll talk about in this space i
wanted to take a brief diversion and
since michael mentioned at the beginning
i want to talk a little bit about some
other work that i've done previously
just to give some context for how i got
interested in
mechanism design in the first place so
a problem that i've been interested in
for a long time
is how can we help people
visualize and understand the the
structure the internal structure of
complex 3d objects that contain lots of
different parts
so you that um so you know for instance
anatomical models or or cad model these
are examples of the types of data sets
that i'm interested in and during my phd
i worked on a bunch of interactive
visualization techniques that are
inspired by traditional technical
illustrations so cutaways and exploded
views and tries to kind of automate
these techniques as much as possible so
that um we can have a kind of
interactive viewing experience and so
what you're seeing here are is just some
videos of these two systems where for
instance the user can just search for
the parts that they care about and the
system will automatically generate
either a cutaway or exploded view that
just shows you those parts
the
these systems also support other types
of interaction like hovering over parts
and also clicking on parts uh to kind of
explore these types of objects a little
bit more interactively
okay so so these types of systems um
one thing that they help people do is
understand the kind of spatial
configurations of parts that exist
inside of these objects but but one
really common
comment that we got from people who saw
this this work was
okay that's great but i really i really
also want to know how these things work
like how does this engine work it's got
lots of moving parts in it
i guess people
did not ask how much how the arm works
so for anatomical data sets it was a
little bit different but especially for
these cad data sets they were like you
know i really want to know not just
where all these parts are
inside of these objects but but how they
work and so that kind of led us to some
follow-on work
where we looked exactly at that at that
question
and so
in this work
we took as input a 3d model so this is
just geometry
know what kind of other annotations
and then given uh given a specification
of some kind of driving input
uh driving force uh at some part
um what we tried to do is to create
visualizations that show how these
things are trying to convey how these
things actually functioned
and some of our
a lot of our visualization techniques
were inspired by
the how things work books that michael
mentioned earlier so for instance these
types of kind of uh
motion arrows that annotate where the
mechanical interactions occur and also
you know how how the parts move
but we were also inspired by a lot of
cognitive psychology research that
really emphasized the importance of the
so-called kind of causal chain of
mechanical interactions uh in
understanding you know how these things
actually work and so here here's a
different visualization that just
highlights each step in the this causal
chain um how the the the force kind of
gets propagated throughout these this
assembly in particular
and then of course um since we have this
information about about how the
since we know something about how this
assembly actually works we can also
create um animations uh like the one you
shoot like the one you see here they're
kind of in an illustrative style but
show the the assembly in motion
so i don't want to go into too much
detail exactly on
on um how this this technique actually
works but i did want to describe the
high level approach because i think it's
relevant to some of the subsequent parts
of the talk
so the high level approach was we took
an input model
on the left again this is just geometry
and then we did some geometric analysis
in order to figure out
you know how this thing actually works
and in particular we construct a graph
we call it an interaction graph but
there are other names for it in um in
the literature as well where each of the
nodes represents an individual part and
the edges represent these mechanical
interactions between parts
so this graph really kind of
defines
or encodes the the functionality the
mechanical functionality of of the um of
the object and based on this graph we
can derive
all the different visualizations that i
just showed you so that was kind of the
overall approach
okay so what does this have to do with
um mechanism design
so
after working on this project project it
kind of occurred to us that one thing we
could try to do is kind of turn this
approach on its head and maybe use that
as a as an approach to helping people
design physical objects or working
mechanical objects so in particular
let's say
as opposed to taking an input model and
then trying to figure out how it
functions
maybe we can ask
people to specify some desired kind of
goal functionality
and then use that
as part of our system as part of a
design system to help people create
working
working mechanical physical designs
so that's kind of the the really high
level approach that the next couple
projects i'll talk about take and you
know just to be really clear here um
you know this this is certainly not a
really a new idea i mean i'm not a i'm
not an expert in mechan mechanical
engineering but i know there's a ton of
work on inverse design this is basically
an inverse design approach on inverse
design that focuses on you know helping
engineers
create things like uh optimize the
design of turbines and airfoils and gear
trains that accomplish specific design
goals um maybe bill can say more about
this at some point but
you know
there's a lot of work out there that
does that my impression is that a lot of
this this existing work um
does still kind of focus on you know how
can we help a mechanical engineer solve
a particularly a particular a specific
challenging design problem and as a
result a lot of the kind of input
functionality in its previous work i
think tends to be somewhat low level so
here's a desired kind of gear ratio for
two particular gears in a gear train
now you know how can we help help the
engineer create that the corresponding
mechanism so what we we've been
interested in exploring are some methods
and some user interfaces as well
that
kind of allow for users to specify some
higher level functionality and hopefully
in doing so kind of open up some
applications
that are that are relevant to people
like you know like like the hobbyists
and the designers and maybe even the
novices that i talked about uh earlier
okay so that's uh that's kind of the
basic approach and um
let's see did we just jump right in yeah
so let's just jump right in and i'll
talk about two these two projects uh
that i've worked on recently
so the first one is really focusing on
hobbyists as a kind of a as a target
audience and the goal is to help them
create um mechanical automata and so
these are things like what you see here
so on the left
these are actually example uh mechanical
toys from the 19th century um and so
they these automata tend to look more or
less like humans and repor perform some
kind of repetitive motions and they're
all mechanically driven so typically
this is one kind of input crank and you
turn it and the thing kind of does
you know performs these these repeated
motions um but you know mechanical
automata are not just things of the past
they exist in our in our current lives
as well and um you know one
one common example are just wind-up toys
there's lots of kind of toys out there
that are still
largely mechanical um but you know even
like in things like uh stage production
and i think theme parks
they still use things that we could more
or less call mechanical automata to
create these kind of like um
moving characters moving physical
characters and uh although i i'm not an
expert in the visual effects i believe
that up until recently visual effects
still also used in some cases you know
mechanical automata to
to create certain types of
certain types of creatures and those
kinds of things
so
you know these are some really
interesting types of mechanisms but
obviously or maybe not obviously
it they're hard to design i mean you
have to worry about a whole bunch of
interacting mechanical components and
have them kind of achieve these specific
target um target motions so the goal in
this project was just just to try to
make it easier for
easier for for users who are not
mechanical engineers who are not expert
toy designers to create these kinds of
of outputs
in particular the the approach the kind
of design pipeline that we took was to
have people specify as input some kind
of motion and this is in the form of an
animation in this case it's motion
capture animation so let's say we have
this input motion
then what the system helps user do in a
largely automated way is to turn that
into
a mechanically realizable form of that
motion
that in you know that also has has
solved for all the different mechanical
parameters of the parts that that will
create that motion and again in this
case we are trying to work with this
kind of single input crank constraint so
this thing can should be able to be
driven by a single input crank
okay and then based on that design
we can now actually fabricate a working
version of the of the automata
automaton
by in this case laser cutting the
different parts and then putting them
putting them together
okay so just
a little bit more detail on how this
actually works i won't go into a lot of
detail
kind of one of the main
insights one of the main um kind of uh
aspects of the technique was you know as
i mentioned before um
we're trying to allow users to provide
some really high level functionality
here and
that makes things challenging like
there's lots of different ways of
achieving any any of these input motions
right and so that's a pretty huge
parameter space of different
configurations that we could consider um
how do we kind of make that problem a
little bit more tractable so the way
that we did it in this case um the the
the way we had of simplifying the
problem was to
come up with a single fixed uh what we
call oscillation module
that has this you know fixed design has
certain sets of gears and in this case a
four bar linkage that's connected to the
gears to kind of turn
rotational motion into oscillating
motion
and then we attach these oscillation
modules to each joint in in the
in the model so now we have basically
the same repeated design it's just a
modular it's a modular design that's
repeated across all the different joints
which really reduces the kind of the
space of different solutions we have to
search over um so it's not quite as
simple as this actually we you know we
have this um this you know kind of a
four-bar linkage we also connect that
that linkage to the next limb inside of
each of the the kind of kinematic chains
of the body so that you see those black
limbs kind of moving back and forth
and then finally in order to be able to
propagate the motion from you know one
joint to the next so let's say the
shoulder to the elbow then we we attach
this kind of pulley mechanism that then
kind of allows the initial kind of
driving rotation to be transferred to
the next the next joint in the chain so
this is kind of the basic um design
element of this technique and
with this oscillation module we
basically
run an optimization that takes that
input motion and then comes up with an
approximated motion as well as the
design that kind of um solves for all
the parameters of the of the module
now i i should say here there's
definitely a trade-off here i mean we on
the one hand we've we've created this
oscillation module that makes the the
parameters you know that reduces the
parameter space we have to care about
but on the flip side it also kind of
restricts the range of different motions
that we can produce right and so
um that is kind of the fundamental
tradeoff that we decided to make um
in spite of that we were able to use
this approach to to kind of reproduce an
interesting range of different motions
so let me just show you a few results
here um so on the left is in each case
is the input motion the middle is kind
of the mechanical motion so it's we're
not showing the mechanisms just yet but
we're just showing you know the
difference between the input motion and
the motion that we're more or less able
to achieve mechanically
with these oscillation modules um
so one one constraint here is that we're
restricting the motion of any individual
um
chain
like the arms or the legs to be planar
but those can exist in different so the
arms can move in a different plane than
the legs it's just that you know each
arm or each leg has to have a more or
less a planar motion
so these are a bunch of different
motions that we grab from a motion
capture data set
and in a minute here you'll see
a couple of the fabricated results
oh yeah we can also use like you know a
connect or something to then demonstrate
the desired input motion and then
produce a
design that reproduces that motion more
or less
so on the fabrication side um you know
this is the walking example that you saw
earlier uh we laser cut all these
different parts including the the the
limbs
and then we um we were able to fabricate
this example and we're driving here with
it with a motor at the top
it's kind of hidden i think but it's
it's being driven from the top
and then there's in a moment here the
second sequence the dancing sequence
which has two different planes of motion
the arms kind of move this way and the
legs move
in another plane
and so that's that's this example here
okay so i already talked about some of
the limitations of this work um they
mainly have to do with our use of this
kind of this fixed oscillation module um
as i said you know we the right now the
motion of each individual limb has to be
in a single plane which is fine for some
motions but let's say for swimming in
the swimming example it really probably
wouldn't work very well
also as i mentioned we are assuming
there's a single input crank that can
drive any of these individual um
individual designs which is on the one
hand good because you know if you have a
wind-up toy you have basically a single
input and you know that's great
but on the other hand it can make for
some pretty complicated like we have to
jump through some hoops actually get all
these different chains connected up all
these different kind of moving parts
connected up so that they can be driven
by a single a single input crank so that
definitely some more work i think that
needs to be done there in order to make
these kind of simpler designs and then
finally
the individual mechanical components we
use inside of our oscillation module
they're really simple they're just gears
and four bar linkages and pulleys
which again restricts the range of
different types of motions that we can
we can produce potentially so if we
consider things like non-circular gears
or more complicated linkages i think
that could really expand the range of
things we could reproduce and in fact
some other
kind of recent work along these lines
does experiment with some of these
different types of components
okay so so
the system for
for um authoring automata that was
really focused on on hobbyists and so as
a result we were trying to go for like a
fairly automated system we more or less
provide this input motion and then the
system generates a result for you um so
that's fine for hobbyists but what if we
want to consider other types of users
for instance industrial designers who
you know
like they're probably going to want to
be creating a wide variety of different
types of things and as a result
a design system for for those types of
users probably needs to be
kind of more flexible and give them more
control over the types of things that
they can create so that was kind of
the direction we moved in for this for
this other project where we're really
focusing on
on designers and helping them create
prototypes
in particular we are focusing on
what some people call works like
prototypes and so these are
prototypes that are you know often
created i think earlier on in the design
process to try to explore
the um kind of the the functional
characteristics of a particular
candidate design this is especially true
for for mechanical objects um
in many cases the actual you know
geometry or the appearance of these
prototypes doesn't have to be very
accurate um the point is not to try to
evaluate how the thing looks or the form
of the um of the candidate design is
more about the
mechanical functionality in
some designers called the mechanical
architecture of these of these objects
um
you know this
probably
is pretty kind of well
well agreed upon well understood at this
point
all the various benefits of prototyping
and so in particular creating these
works like prototypes i think can really
help um
uh help designers go through multiple
iterations in the design cycle which can
lead to often leads to kind of better
design exploration
so
the goal here is to try to make it
easier for these designers to create
these kinds of works like prototypes and
then contribute to this some
better design exploration as a result
so
the the main challenge that we kind of
um uh identified here in talking and
talking to some designers about their
process is that
going from the concept of some kind of
mechanical design to
uh to a working prototype of that design
is often kind of challenging i mean even
if it's a relatively simple even if the
the prototype is relatively simple
geometry as you see here um there's lots
of
things to think about like you know
where to put the joints what are the
joint parameters what are the dimensions
of all the parts so that everything kind
of fits together
nicely so
you know
going from design to to to these working
prototypes involves kind of addressing
some of these challenges and while some
designers are are probably capable of
doing that um many others kind of have
to
rely on working with engineers or um or
other kind of experts cad experts to try
to help them do this and so this is kind
of the the part of the of the workflow
that we were trying to trying to address
and trying to um
facilitate
okay so the specific design pipeline
that we
uh that we adopt is
from a design we
we um
we have the we expect that the the user
is going to create a really rough model
of the object so in this case you don't
have to worry so much about exactly how
the parts line up you know where the
joint should go exactly um
uh the various joint parameters just
kind of create a rough model that's
that's based on your initial design
and then
what we allow
the user to do is now specify specific
functional relationships between
different parts of this of this design
or different parts of this of this 3d
model in this case so for instance you
might say that one part of the model has
to cover another part of the model
or you might say that one part of the
the design has to fit inside another
part of the design
another another functional relationship
we support is
support so one object should be
supported by other one part should be
supported by other parts inside of the
design
so by specifying these kind of
functional relationships the user is
kind of
telling us something about what is the
desired functionality of this object
that they've kind of roughly modeled
so based on this this information we're
able to kind of
create or update the the initial rough
model and turn that into a working
design so now the part dimensions have
been updated to
to match or to satisfy all these
functional requirements and also we've
generated joints and joint parameters
joints with the appropriate joint
parameters to allow
this design to actually work and then we
can send this design to uh let's say a
3d printer or some other rapper
prototyping
technology and then get a working
prototype in the end
okay so i'll just say a little bit more
again i'm not going to say a lot about
exactly how this works but
you know basically one of the the key
contributions here was just figuring out
a way of mapping these functional
relationships which you know are
specified at a really high level like
you know this this part of the cabinet
has to cover this other part of the
cabinet mapping those onto a set of
geometric constraints that we could then
use inside of an optimization to take
that rough initial model and turn it
into a working model
so let me just show you a little bit of
the system in action so here's
this kind of rough initial model let's
say i want these two doors of this of
this this cabinet to actually fit
or cover exactly the front of the
cabinet so if i specify that
relationship you can see you know a
bunch of the part dimensions have been
updated to make sure that that's the
case and also to avoid collisions
this is kind of an example of a fit
inside relationship this is pretty
pretty clear so i want this drawer to
fit just inside of the
the printer cabinet um so that gets
updated and in this case i'm saying i
want the top of this kind of folding uh
bunk bed thing to kind of be supported
by by all the parts underneath of it and
this is kind of the update that the
system makes
so one advantage of having these
functional relationships kind of
explicitly encoded in the system is that
once we have them we can also allow the
user to explore design variations while
maintaining these functional
relationships so here you know i say oh
the doors have to cover the front of the
cabinets and they also in this case have
to fit inside
so you know those those relationships
relationships are known so now as i
change the size of these different
components
the entire cabinet updates appropriately
okay so now given
given these designs i'll just show
here a few of the fabricated prototypes
that we um
that we
that we produced
and you'll notice that these have a you
know a few different types of of joints
and different types of parts
they have hinges and sliding hinges
and
uh um
and just kind of sliding parts
um
and you know i guess as this plays i'll
just talk again a bit about a couple of
the limitations of this approach so you
know these examples just demonstrate
to some extent the range of different
objects that we were able to to produce
but you know we're right now only
supporting really simple geometric
primitives you know i said at the outset
that works like prototypes tend to have
pretty simple geometry that's true but
sometimes you know
just having boxes and cylinders is not
quite enough in particular uh one
example we talked to um
one of the one of the designers who we
talked to mentioned that often for for
the works like prototypes that he
creates he wants to see how an existing
object kind of fits inside of some other
kind of
mechanical uh housing that he's
designing so let's say like a like a
case for an iphone let's say or
something along those lines so even if
the actual geometry of the
of the of the parts of the prototype
don't need to be particularly
detailed having those parts fit with
other real objects is kind of a nice a
nice feature and so
you know i think clearly to make this
this approach more more useful we'd want
to consider these different types of
different types of geometric primitives
to use as parts
also you know we we right now only
support a few different types of
functional relationships um there's many
other functional relationships i think
could be important
again that same designer mentioned uh
snap fitting as a as one potential um
relationship or like yeah kind of like
screwing things together or something
along those lines um so you know there's
clearly more work to be done
this is the bunk that we showed earlier
i think it wasn't probably wasn't very
clear from the
from the 3d model how this thing was
supposed to work or what it's supposed
to do but it's kind of this folding sofa
bunk design
okay so these are
you know just kind of two points in the
space
but
there has actually been a lot of work
recently in the in the graphics and hci
communities
on things related to to mechanism design
and so
um you know some of this work is very
related to things that i showed um
others are kind of less related like for
instance on the bottom right it's a cool
paper from siggraph last year where
they're creating things that spin so
basically you take a 3d model as input
and you want to try to make it spin like
a top so you know that's kind of a
functional goal that somebody might have
and so that's um that's what that work
focuses on
um so these are just two points in the
space i you know and there's lots of
kind of work going on in in this area
right now i do think though that there's
lots more work that could be done so i
think this is a pretty open space lots
of different domains and different types
of functionality that you can imagine
trying to like
support in these kinds of design systems
and i just wanted to show one specific
example of a it's kind of an
inspirational example of something that
that i saw again at this graph last year
that made me think about an interesting
new direction that i think is worth
worth pursuing
so some of you may have heard of
not impossible labs uh but they gave the
keynote at um siggraph last year
and
what they do is they try to go out and
use technology to to try to solve
specific problems for specific people so
in this case um this boy daniel who uh
uh lives in a village in sudan was you
know tragically lost both of his arms in
a in an embalming
and they went and they
built him a prosthetic arm that allowed
him to um eat by himself so basically
in moving the arm um er moving the arm
kind of also control the the hand of the
of the arm so he could kind of reach out
grab things and then bring them up to
his mouth and you know this is kind of a
made a big difference in his quality of
life but as you're seeing right now not
only did they build a single solution
they tried to basically educate
um
the rest of the village and this in some
sense kind of open source the solution
so that other people could actually
build
similar kinds of
prosthetics based on the same design
and i thought that was you know really
like it's a really simple observation
it's a really actually noble kind of um
uh
goal but the simple
observation was that
you know it took us a lot of
it took a lot of expertise and effort to
actually create this one working design
now how can we leverage that as much as
possible to help other people kind of
take advantage of that and so
i think um
there's to me there seems like at least
a couple of different well this is one
kind of main opportunity here from kind
of a computer graphics or hdi research
side which is that
i think
if we can think about ways of taking
individual working designs and then
parameterizing them in ways that makes
it make it easier for those designs to
be kind of
adapted to different situations so
clearly in the case of the prosthetic
like everyone's got a different arm
different shaped arm you know there's
clearly parameters that have to be kind
of customized
that's an interesting problem i think
and i think it's one that's worth worth
trying to address
so
that's kind of the the that's kind of
where i'll leave off the first part of
my talk which is really focusing on
mechanical design and some of the some
of the opportunities there
let me go back to this slide from the
beginning of my talk
as i started out with started out by
saying there are lots of other kind of
interesting domains of physical objects
that we consider we can consider trying
to build design tools for
um and so far we've been talking about
mechanisms and their functionality but
you know what about these other these
other domains um
i think there's some really nice
opportunities here and so what i'll what
i'll do for the last the second part of
my talk is just kind of talk about more
opportunities and a little bit of
ongoing work but this is this is not
work that i've done already this is just
kind of some stuff that i've been
thinking about that i think is um you
know could be interesting to work on
um so let me start with a bit of an
observation we've talked a lot about
functionality and in particular
mechanical functionality but those
clearly are not the only design goals
that go into making physical objects the
one ones that we see in the world around
us and just as a couple of examples you
know this
this sculpture by rodin is not just a
kind of anatomically plausible
representation of a reclining figure
that happens to balance and you know sit
flat on a surface
just like you know this
these chairs are not just some
collection of wood and metal and
fiberglass that
you know that a human can sit on i mean
clearly they have a functional purpose
but that's not the only
that's not the only goal here
you know for these objects as well as
many others
the the artists and designers who are
creating them are using a variety of
techniques to kind of um
convey certain emotions or convey
certain aspects that are beyond just
function and
i think it's interesting for us to maybe
think about how we could
try to be inspired by and leverage some
of these uh some of these existing
techniques
that that artists and designers have
created in order to build better
computational tools
um
so as a uh as a computer graphics person
it occurred to me that um there's a
potential an analogy we could draw here
to the advent of um a field called
non-photorealistic rendering which some
of you may have heard about um
basically you know in the history of
computer graphics um
people started out for a long time just
trying to create more and more realistic
renderings images of of you know 3d
models of things that exist in the world
today trying to emulate um
emulate reality as much as possible and
so you know these are just some examples
here these are all
rendered images um and it may be harder
to tell for some of them that these are
actually rendered images
this resulted in a lot of really
important advances in computer graphics
so this is great
but at some point some researchers
began to think about
and look at some you know other forms of
of depiction and in particular um they
looked a lot at things like illustration
and painting which use very different
kinds of of rendering styles depiction
styles
in order to
you know represent represent things in
the world and represent scenes
and
you know these
these different rendering styles kind of
inspire this whole this whole field of
render of computer graphics
which is often called non-photorealistic
rendering
to develop
computational tools and
algorithms
to try to make use of some of these
techniques from illustration and
painting as a way of creating
computer-generated imagery and
you know this is i think
as a field we're kind of better off for
it right i mean like clearly there are
some a lot of really important
applications for creating super
photorealistic renderings
but these other forms of depiction have
a lot of advantages as well especially
in terms of emphasizing
certain aspects of a drawing emphasizing
certain aspects of an image or every
scene and you know it's basically just
expand expanded the expressive range of
computer generated imagery so you know
that i think that's been a great
development um
maybe we can think of a similar thing
happening for the creation of 3d objects
so can we be inspired by and leverage
some of the techniques that 3d artists
and designers
use and have been using for a long time
in order to create
tools and algorithms that that produce a
wider range of different kinds of 3d
objects
let me
try to make this a little bit more
concrete by going through some examples
of techniques that i think could
potentially inform
informed design tools for creating 3d
objects
so one really simple one i'll go back to
this example that i showed before is
simply about abstraction and of course
abstraction is a big element of a lot of
2d um artwork as well illustration and
painting but in 3d it's it's you know it
may not be quite as obvious but 3d it
exists in 3d as well so
for uh sculpture sculptors who create
busts of human heads
they they often refer to this
abstraction called the planes of the
head which is a set of of planes that
define more or less the kind of key
characteristics of a person's
uh a person's a person's head and and
their face and you know the what they
look like and so in order to create
really kind of um compelling and
recognizable bus of humans they often
kind of end up abstracting away a lot of
the details and really focusing on these
these different planes of the head
for kind of full body anatomy uh like as
in this example here um
abstraction is also happening clearly i
mean uh maybe it may be a little bit
hard to see in in this slide or in this
room but
um the the face and the hair of this of
this figure are clearly you know
abstracted away a lot there's not a lot
of detail there whereas kind of the back
and other parts of the form have a lot
more detail
i found this other version i mean this
is not another another version of that
sculpture just a different version a
different sculpture that seemed kind of
related where you know the abstraction
is even more kind of obvious and so
these you know by using abstraction we
these artists can kind of help focus the
viewer on specific aspects of the form
um and in this case maybe just have them
focus less on on the
the uh the figure herself and more just
on kind of these these um these shapes
and these contours
i think something that's clearly related
to abstraction and maybe um not quite
opposite but you know a
a different way of kind of manipulating
form is to exaggerate things
and there's a variety of different ways
that artists exaggerate form so on the
left we have an example of exaggerating
a pose so this is a sculpture
sculpture that sits outside of 18 t park
in san francisco and you know here the
pose of this picture is being
exaggerated to kind of really emphasize
the tension in this moment right before
the pitch is thrown um
actually i looked up this particular
picture because i was curious after i
saw this on the sculpture and this is
actually not exaggerated that much this
picture has a very particular kind of uh
pitching motion but it's exaggerated to
some extent
um
and of course you know exaggeration
happens in the actual form of these
objects forms of objects as well so in
uh in the burgers of calais uh the hands
and the feet of these figures are kind
of much larger than they would than they
would really really be um and you know
some have speculated this is kind of to
emphasize the the kind of feeling of
despair
of these figures
so if we
you know we've talked about form thus
far but there's also a lot of
abstraction and exaggeration that goes
into texture as well so in these cases
the textures of these various uh in this
case i guess it's all animals
they've been exaggerated to kind of
emphasize some of the the features of
these
of these
of these objects and you know there may
be different reasons for exaggerating
and abstracting away texture but um but
this is clearly something a technique
that that that artists use as well
conveying motion is another kind of
interesting challenge especially if
you're considering a static
static sculpture
so before i talked about creating these
automata but these are static sculptures
and you really do get a sense for the
motion of this ballerina as well as
motion of this wave and
again i think pose is a good way of of
uh pose is one tool that artists can use
to kind of uh convey and emphasize
certain aspects of emotion but you know
an example on the right this is kind of
a
i think an interesting use of texture to
kind of try to convey that convey that
motion as well
i talked a little bit earlier about
materials
you know i don't have a lot of expertise
in this domain but i
i'm sure that
designers who you know create things
like furniture furniture for instance
think a lot about materials when they're
trying to trying to you know convey is
this like a luxury chair or is this a
kind of something that's supposed to
look more modern or something that has a
different kind of feel to it so i think
materials and the choice materials is
clearly a really important uh tool as
well
this is a
another example that
i found kind of interesting i i have
some interest in just kind of miniatures
i feel like they're really interesting
if you ever kind of see like a miniature
of like a car or some some some object
it's kind of interesting what
what details are left and what details
are abstracted away so this
you know could be related again to the
what i talked about earlier with respect
to abstraction but i think in the case
of of creating miniatures it's kind of a
very particular type of abstraction it's
i think it's related to
i think it's related to icons in in in
that you know let's say you have a set
of headphones that's kind of the thing
you want to represent if you create a 2d
icon of those headphones you're kind of
trying to keep certain details
and abstract away others to still make
sure that that that that icon remains
recognizable and has some features of
the um of the original object but it's
also legible so clearly you can't
include all the details i think
similarly we can think of creating
miniature sculptures or miniature 3d
objects as kind of this iconization
problem in some sense but in in 3d so i
think it's kind of an interesting thing
to think about
there's also
i think a lot to be gained by thinking
about what intermediate representations
artists use to create these different
types of artwork so in the case of um
bio-relief wood carvings as you can see
on the top
uh
oftentimes artists will start with some
kind of
initial illustration and then simplify
it and annotate it in various ways in
order to come up with the final design
that then that they then carve into the
wood um and so
thinking about
how artists use these intermediate
representations um what they uh
you know what they do with them how they
how that kind of illustrates or or
elucidates part of their their design
thinking i think is is an interesting
potential opportunity
similarly we can we can think about
concept sketches in product design as
another type of intermediate
representation
so
that's a bunch of kind of specific
examples of possible techniques from
from from art and design that we could
you know maybe use to help inform design
tools let me just talk really briefly
about one last project which is kind of
some ongoing work that
it's just kind of one example of how we
can we can hopefully leverage some of
this uh some of this information to
build a specific design tool
so this uh
in this work we're really focused on the
problem of helping people design um what
is sometimes called wire wrapped jewelry
it's a very different domain than then
mechanisms
and this is the type of jewelry that
we're talking about it's i guess it's
kind of obvious it's wire that's wrapped
in some particular way to create
some kind of design
and so you know one one observation
about these uh wire wrapped jewelry
pieces is that they often start our
sketches which is probably not
surprising to you to you all
and
so the sketch you can think of that as
either the input or in some sense
already kind of an intermediate
representation um probably like an
unannotated sketch
you know that's probably more like the
input to this design process but at some
point you have to take that sketch and
then figure out how you know how the
different parts of the sketch correspond
to the different segments of wire that
you're going to you know attach together
to create the final piece of jewelry and
so
the
the problem or the kind of the the the
approach that we've been taking is to
say okay well let's say you have an
input drawing so it's provided maybe by
either you find this drawing somewhere
you or you create the drawing yourself
and now you want to turn it into this
piece of jewelry um how can we help how
can how can we help make that process
happen and as i said before kind of the
main the main design challenges here are
the main challenges and going from the
thing on the left to the thing on the
right are
one to figure out which parts of that
drawing kind of correspond should
correspond to different wire segments
and then actually kind of doing this
wrapping like how do you actually create
the final thing from um
from the from the design
and the pipeline that we've
uh that we've come up with is kind of a
two-stage thing so first from the input
drawing we just want to help people come
up with with this wire design which more
or less is just a segmentation into the
different wire components and then kind
of interestingly um to help them go from
that design to the final piece of
jewelry
we are investig investigating some
techniques to kind of help them
print these kind of custom what we're
calling custom jigs that will then allow
them to kind of wrap that piece of
jewelry in a reasonable way
so i'm not going to say very much at all
but about the approach here
we kind of formulate this problem of
taking an input drawing and turning it
into this kind of segmented wire design
as a graph a graph based energy
minimization problem
so um we're just trying to figure out
okay you know should we take this
segment and turn it into one piece of a
wire and then this other segment should
be another piece of wire and there's a
bunch of kind of design goals that we
try to kind of incorporate into that
optimization like you know you obviously
don't want uh one segment to like stop
somewhere in the middle and then like
another segment they're going to meet it
at a sharp angle because that's going to
be hard to attach and it's not going to
look very good and that kind of thing so
there's a bunch of different kind of uh
i guess energy terms that go into the
that represent these different design
goals that we're going to use inside of
this optimization
let me just show you some results so
these are some preliminary results
where you know we take an as input the
drawing that's shown in black in the
middle
and these are these were kind of
inspired by real pieces of jewelry that
we saw online um so in some sense we're
kind of cheating because we know there
is a
solution already but on the other hand
we can kind of evaluate our solution
against what was actually created um so
you know in simple cases like the
butterfly we can actually represent the
whole thing with a single piece of wire
so that's kind of like the ideal case
but in other situations we have to kind
of use multiple pieces of wire to
realize the design so that's kind of the
case that you see here in the bottom
here are some other examples that are a
little bit more complicated um you know
we're trying to run these on much more
complicated
input illustrations as well
you could probably argue that for the
examples that you see here you know the
the segmentations we're coming up with
are you know somewhat obvious
that maybe yes go ahead so just
clarification yeah
this is motivated by like taking wires
sort of wrapping around 3d printing
like is it actually wired at all or is
it just sort of no yes
i'll get that we're actually not
printing these these outfits at all so
the
you know part of the challenge here with
wi-rap jewelry is that you it's really
hard to print
these really thin filaments and you know
kind of get them to wrap or anything so
we're still actually
there's still a human kind of involved
in the fabrication process you know
maybe maybe it is actually the next
slide yeah okay so there's still a human
involved in the fabrication process so
let's say you know i have have an
illustration and i get this design this
is this design just involves a single
piece of wire and now i have to kind of
i now want to create this this piece of
jewelry um so
what
you would you could do right now without
any assistance from our from our tools
just to
take that piece of wire um cut it to the
right length and then use a pair of
pliers and your hands and whatnot to try
to create the final result
i'm not going to show i don't have a
picture of what that would look like
like but it would look bad trust me like
it's really hard to get the wire to
basically bend smoothly and in the right
spots
and so what we've been
trying to think of are ways in which we
can help
help people you know take their designs
once you get to this stage and create
the final piece of jewelry um
without you know being able to actually
3d print that piece of jewelry directly
right and so um the approach that we're
taking is to actually create these kind
of custom jigs so given the design which
our system now knows about
can we create can we 3d print a jig that
you can then use to kind of help wrap
wrap wire around in order to create the
final results
these are just a couple of kind of
initial experiments that we've been
doing along these lines the one on the
top is kind of like the obvious solution
right like i have this 2d design more or
less and i want to have the wire
basically represent that design why
don't i just kind of extrude the whole
thing
make a groove where i can put the wire
into and then wrap things around it
what's interesting here actually is that
we found that that wasn't actually that
easy to use so it produced a reasonable
result so the thing on the top is is
what was produced with that kind of
extruded
version but it was really hard to kind
of keep that wire
tucked inside of that groove and you
didn't have any way of kind of pulling
applying tension to the wire as you went
around so that was kind of interesting
we thought so we've been experimenting
with different actually other types of
jigs that we can derive from a given
design
in order to kind of make that wrap that
wrapping process easier and so that's
kind of the part of the work that's not
really done yet where we've been
exploring different ways in which we
could kind of create these jigs but
obviously we want to be able to do that
automatically or computationally given
the design
so that's kind of
you know where that project is at
so that's kind of an interesting i think
you know i'm excited about about that
project i think actually in general
jewelry is an interesting domain for uh
thinking about design tools
but i think there's some other
opportunities as well so let me just
leave you with a few other specific
opportunities that i think are kind of
fun things to to work on and you know
for some of you i might be interested i
mean if i'm happy to talk about possible
projects to do because i'm always
looking for for um for cool people to
work with
um
so here are a bunch of different kind of
automated or semi-automated design tools
that i can imagine
kind of coming out of some of the
observations that i uh that i made
earlier so
with respect to kind of doing
abstraction of sculptures
one possible design tool could involve
taking like a 3d scan of of your bust of
like a
person's head and shoulders and then
um kind of modifying that scan
and abstracting it in kind of a
sculptural way basically so knowing
about the planes of the head knowing
about certain types of exaggerations
that that
that that sculptors use can we kind of
basically improve these 3d scans
of people's heads and turn them into
nicer looking sculptures
and so this is actually a project that
some of some of my colleagues at adobe
have been doing in collaboration with
other folks and so it's kind of an
ongoing project but i thought it was so
cool like actually that's
learning about that project was one of
the
reasons i started thinking about this
whole space of like how can we kind of
learn from from 3d artists and build
some better design tools so i think
that's a that's one great example um
as i mentioned before i've been
interested in this problem of like
turning 3d objects into like what i
would call 3d icons or like smaller
versions of them where
you're trying to figure out which
details to retain and which details to
kind of abstract away in order to create
a final result that's both recognizable
as well as legible at that size so i
think that could be an interesting
problem to work on
um
i talked a little bit about
how uh artists who work in in relief
kind of go from um input drawings to the
kind of final design so i think there
similarly with the wire wrap jewelry
project maybe we can think about ways of
helping them kind of move along that
that that workflow kind of going from
these input illustrations to the final
design um you know that could involve
things like simplifying different parts
of the illustration and figuring out you
know where to put certain types of
undercuts or certain types of um
features physical features so that i
think that's a potentially an
interesting project to do as well
and finally
you know
going back to that that sculpture of the
picture outside of att park you know i
think it could be kind of cool to start
from motion capture data which where you
have the motion you know if you know the
emotion that you're trying to
represent and then turn that into um a
static form of it a sculpture that
represents that motion in some kind of
interesting way so um
that that technique could involve trying
to exaggerate certain aspects of the
pose or certain aspects of the
proportions in order to kind of really
um emphasize through different different
aspects of the motion
in kind of a different space and not
talking so much about design tools but
probably related to design tools we
could think about trying to synthesize
or understand um
what stylistic elements of different uh
objects are kind of similar or different
and maybe use those for synthesis um or
or maybe making automated design
suggestions so i don't have a lot to say
about this because it's kind of kind of
high level and vague in my mind but i
think this could be an interesting
opportunity
to look at
and then finally even more vague
and hand-wavy um you know one of the
nice kind of outcomes of the work on
non-photorealistic rendering
in graphics has been
to gain some insights actually by
looking at um you know what lines
artists draw or what lines people draw
about how we perceive things
and you know that's that's kind of a
cool result i mean i i've not been
involved in that work but that's i think
a really nice um
a nice outcome for that branch of
research so maybe uh by analyzing and
understanding more what techniques 3d
artists use
maybe we can gain some insights on how
we as humans perceive things like form
and texture possibly that could be a
cool thing to investigate
um
and that's it for my talk so i think
i've left some time for questions um
i'd be happy to answer them now thanks
oh that's uh
you know it's i think
what i think i think it's actually a
human size i i don't think it's huge um
i'm not sure though it's not yours it's
not mine no it's nice
it's good too yeah i thought it was
really nice actually unfortunately i
forgot the note in my in the notes where
this actually came from so i can't even
tell you who the artist is but um i can
try to find it if you're interested
i want to wear
so you started out by talking about
makes works like prototypes right so
sort of essentially they're functional
prototypes they're trying to ask the
question of
you know i have this vision that i think
this would be feasible could i actually
build a thing that mechanically does
this yeah i wonder if we shifted our
view towards something that's not quite
a functional or works like prototype but
something like almost like a
might work like prototype something
that's more like i want to have this
thing you know
flat wings when i do this is yeah
i think it would get less focused on the
details of how do i create armature that
sort of exactly reproduces this thing
and more about sort of
fluidly conceptualizing new
new points of view or new ways of going
about this which especially in the early
stages of that feels like what you what
you really want to be enabling not the
yeah i don't know how to do this it's
just you know eventually eventually some
mechanical engineer can take this and as
long as it's feasible they can figure
out how to do it i just want to know if
i can if you know it would be even
feasible to collapse this yeah that's a
really nice that's a nice observation
and i think for sure you know there's
kind of different parts of this kind of
uh
different parts of the conceptualization
of a of a pro of a possible design
there's kind of like you know
this kind of broader uh uh idea that as
you're saying like oh what if i make
like a
um a chair that can fold up into a box
like you know that's kind of like a
high-level i'm like oh like this okay
this is kind of an interesting idea to
explore is it even feasible
i'm not sure
the part of the design process of the
design process that we were more
focusing on is
you know once you're a little bit
further down that road you're like okay
i think this is going to work let me
create a physical thing that lets me
kind of evaluate how and how it's
working and whether this feels right
so i think there is a nice opportunity
opportunity to say okay can we can we
give i have a design system that takes
even higher level functional kind of
potential functional goals like this may
not even be feasible as you're saying
and then tries to kind of explore some
different possibilities give me some
suggestions and say oh you know i can i
think you can do this kind of this way
or maybe this other way um or you know
this particular or this particular idea
is not even feasible at all i think you
know could be really useful as you're
saying kind of at that earlier stage in
the in the
in the design cycle um so yeah i mean we
were kind of more focused on a
on a somewhat kind of smaller more
specific problem which is simply it's
more one of execution like
i i have this design in mind and i know
it's i know how it's supposed to work i
know it's going to work i just um i just
want to actually realize it in a way
that that allows me to kind of test it
physically and so that's kind of the
part that we were um focused on but yeah
i think that's a
well you what you talked about is a
really nice
um and sounds like a challenging problem
to try to try to address we're rummaging
around in an interesting space here
because i feel like motion is the thing
that's hard both in computer traditional
graphical interfaces and physical
interfaces the thing that's hardest to
conceptualize in your mind's eye yeah
last week we had a speaker in my class
who's a motion graphics designer for
google and had done a bunch of work in
the film industry before he went to
google and it's very different like they
have to do all the stuff in after
effects so like in order to get anything
that like eventually becomes like you
know flipping hamburger icons saying
android yeah it seems like
making that process of like what would
it be like if the thing swung over what
would that like i feel like there's such
such opportunity there yeah i mean
almost like there's an input modality
like if you can also make use of motion
like it's like here here's like how do
we
yeah i think that would
yeah that's really interesting yeah
um
so
i
the the thing that makes me think that
this makes me think about is
how much
the product
what's the process which
which designers or people making things
are going through
versus i want this thing in a sort of
functional specification
which seems to run through a lot of the
work as opposed to
you know
another way to think about i want to
create this mechanical object is i'm
going to get a bunch of stuff and throw
it on the um
a desk and now i'm going to start you
know sticking it together with
plato and
it seems like there's a more
not just exploratory process but it's
tactile yeah it's a different sense of
it it seems like that's a different way
of thinking yeah and so i wonder how
much these tools
not just
provide for people to like oh here's
here's a way to do this easier but
really it it's recasting the whole
creation process as something more
symbolic or more declarative yeah i mean
i that's a that's a good point um i'm
not exactly sure how to respond to it
because i don't think i know the answer
um i think that
you're you're you're right that
i can certainly imagine aspects of the
process or examples of this process
happening in a much more exploratory way
and in fact
one thing i'm really interested in in
looking at uh that's related to works
like prototypes or prototyping in
general is how to go from these
so-called like junk prototypes that
designers often create early on like
using like foam core and like wire and
whatever they have at the disposal to
just try to get a sense for this initial
you know like how could this thing work
um to you know to the things that i was
kind of showing um
and
you know i think maybe one potential
answer is to say okay well can can we
more directly integrate the results of
that kind of junk prototyping um because
you know one of the disadvantages with
one of the advantages of using physical
things is that they're just there
they're tactile as you're saying you can
explore them you don't you know you
often you know designers use things that
are immediately at their disposal so
it's incredibly immediate but then you
know if you want to explore a design
variation on this one thing that you've
constructed out of cardboard and paper
that's hard you have to build another
one or destroy this one and so like
digital tools have these nice advantages
of like undo and like save and copy and
paste and like all these kinds of things
so if there's some way we can help
bridge that gap that would be that could
be really cool right because then you
might get some of the benefits of both
of these worlds um
but you know i'm not really answering
your question i think that
i think that in part the uh
one of the observations with with the
works like prototyping um that project
was that
i think there are some cases where this
kind of declarative notion of
functionality especially at the level of
this thing covers this other thing this
thing is supposed to fit inside you know
can be a useful alternative to just
really low level geometric editing or
just directly editing their parameters
without that information and so that's
kind of the
initial kind of place where we started
from saying we can surely make this
process better
um maybe we can we can make the process
fundamentally better by considering some
of the things that you um that you've
talked about which yeah we did we didn't
have a chance to do basically
metaphor i mean like although also has
been thinking about like you know what
if the designer could leave their junk
prototype out of play-doh or whatever on
the desk overnight yeah and come back
and it's actually much nicer and maybe
it has some armature or something yeah
like the like it's like jello i leave it
in
sets a bit more yeah i mean maybe yeah
maybe that that piece of junk that you
leave has gone off and built some other
things on its own
that could be really cool
as well
you